what's your strategy to win big brother
canada my strategy to win big brother
canada is to play in a really great
social game and to really align myself
with some like-minded individuals i also
want to be a competition beast what kind
of personality will you clash with the
most in that house
i will the type of personality that i
will clash most with is probably
somebody that is egotistical someone
that probably likes to mansplain a lot
um anything along those lines just isn't
my vibe
what's the biggest mansplaining pet
peeve you have the biggest mansplaining
pet peeve i have is when i say something
and then someone repeats what i say in
their own manly way
so what are you gonna do is that type of
person if that
if that type of person is in the house i
will probably just fake it until i make
it
but showman's or no
there will be no match for me i'm very
happy in my relationship right now
um why is
canada for you this winter
canada is gonna root for me because
they're gonna see my energy is high i'm
a super positive individual i'm
representing edmonton alberta and i want
to showcase my background which is from
ethiopia so
let's go i'm excited